hundreds lined the streets law
enforcement members lined the streets as
well as
a umc of umc rather is trooper micah
may's body was escorted to the coroner's
office today
thank you for joining us tonight at six
o'clock i'm sasha loftis
nhp trooper may lost his life this week
he had been fighting to survive at umc
after he was hit by a car
during a chase on the i-15 victoria saha
joins us live tonight with more victoria
sasha the procession ended here at the
coroner's office from
umc hundreds of community members and
law enforcement lined the streets of umc
to salute trooper micah may as his body
was brought here at the coroner's office
and that's where he'll be spending the
night here
earlier today at umc where several
members of the nevada highway patrol and
other law enforcement agencies gathered
there as they prepared to escort trooper
may's body his squad car was also parked
in front of the hospital
it's been four days since trooper may
was struck by an alleged carjacker as he
was laying down spike strips
leaving him in critical condition
trooper may died on thursday
the nevada highway patrol says they have
not left his side since this incident
happened
and they're all grieving the loss of
their brother together
knowing michael or micah may
having worked with him several years
this is painful
i'm glad that i've had the people around
me supporting me that i've had
it's allowed me to come out here and be
able to share with the community
trooper may is a father of two and the
injured police officers fund has set up
an account to help
trooper may's family which trooper
smekka says is part of the nhp family
now
on tuesday evening there will be a
candlelight vigil to honor trooper may
at the police memorial fund memorial
park excuse me
and we're told that everyone is invited
reporting live victoria saha 8 news now